i'm doing pretty well i have uh four
black friends right now it's the best
i've ever done and uh
all my black friends tell me i'm the
whitest guy they know which i'm i'm not
sure what that means i guess because i
say words like skedaddle i don't know
but yeah
um
i don't know maybe i am super white i
think the widest thing about me is the
fact that after i get a haircut i like
to leave the barbershop
right
yeah i don't see all the need for all
the hanging around you know
you guys don't do that at a dentist's
office you know you don't get a root
canal and go that was great i'm gonna
sit in the lobby for four hours yeah
and i know some people like hey buddy
that's a stereotype well they made three
movies about it so you figure it out
yeah um